swift a multi-paradigm compiled language
created by apple famous for building
apps that grow inside of apple's walled
garden it was first introduced in 2014
at the worldwide developers conference
and was designed as a modern successor
to objective-c the original apple
platform language that had been in use
since the 1980s swift interops with
objective-c but provides a shorter more
readable syntax and features like memory
safety and type inference to improve
developer productivity today it's used
to build mobile apps on ios desktop apps
on mac os wearable apps for watch os but
is also open source which means it can
be used to build software outside of
apple platforms it compiles to native
machine code and is built on top of the
llvm tool chain like many other modern
languages however it also supports a
readable print loop allowing you to
experiment with code in a playground
without needing to recompile making it a
great language for beginners in addition
it provides memory safety by preventing
you from writing unsafe code by default
and uses automatic reference counting to
manage memory automatically to get
started install it then create a file
ending in.swift your code will start
executing in the global scope there's no
need for a main function create a
variable with the var keyword followed
by its name and value var creates a
mutable variable which means its value
can change in the future let on the
other hand creates an immutable variable
or constant it uses type inference to
strongly type the value as a string but
we can explicitly type it by adding a
semicolon after the variable name every
variable must be initialized with a
value unless the type has a question
mark which makes it an optional type
allowing it to also contain a nil value
it also supports optional chaining
making it really easy to work with nil
values functions are declared with the
fun keyword and will use named
parameters by default place an
underscore before the name to use
positional arguments instead now use a
backslash with parentheses to
interpolate these values into a string
functions in swift are first class
objects they can be passed as arguments
used as return values and nested to
create closures it also supports
object-oriented patterns like classes
and inheritance to encapsulate the var
and fung keywords that you just learned
now pull up the terminal and run the
swift compiler to convert your code into
a high performance executable
congratulations your code is now ready
to seek approval on the apple app store
this has been the swift programming
language in 100 seconds if you want to
see more short videos like this make
sure to hit the like button and
subscribe thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one